this video is brought to you by nordvpn give
yourself options online go to nordvpn.com
forward slash biographics to get a
two-year plan with a huge discount
plus four additional months
for free more on them in a bit
try and picture the stereotype of a 20th century
latin american dictator what do you see we're
guessing it involves absurd military uniforms
callous disregard for human life and an ego so big
it could be seen from space now take all of those
qualities and dial them up inflating each one
until it becomes just a mere caricature a cartoon
villain of a human being well congratulations
you're now about halfway to imagining the absurd
bloodthirsty tyrant who was raphael trujillo
absolute ruler of the dominican republic from 1930
to 1961 trio was the proto-typical latin american
caudillo vain pompous and unbelievably sadistic
under his watch the entire population was subject
to arbitrary detention torture and murder all
while blazing neon signs proliferated beaming his
name into the caribbean knight yet it wasn't just
his vice-like grip on his own nation that kept
trio in power hailed as a reformer and ally by the
u.s trio enjoyed access to senators and presidents
even as his regime conducted racial massacres and
plotted the assassination of world leaders today
biographics is delving into the life of one of
the bloodiest dictators in latin american history
in the dark days of the truatto there were
certain things that no one in the dominican
republic could say out loud much of it
was standard dictator stuff criticizing
the regime whispering aloud the tyron's mocking
nickname of the goat but some of it was stranger
more personal for instance there was an official
version of raphael trio's background one that
got taught in schools one that covered his
aristocratic european ancestors in my new detail
but woe betide anyone who dared go beyond that
to whisper the truth during the regime there was
no quicker way to get yourself murdered than
by openly discussing the goat's working-class
non-white roots born raphael leonidas tree home
molina the future dictator first opened his eyes
on the 24th of october 1891 in a village on
the southern coast the third of a staggering
11 children trio ended a family that wasn't just
blue collar but actively poor to supplement his
income the boy's dad would rustle cattle rather
than go to school trio was sporadically educated
by willing neighbors but while his unglamorous
origins would cause him shame in later life
they would have nothing on his ancestry trio's
mother yusu was half black the product of a
union between a dominican and a haitian and in
that place in that era nothing could be a source
of greater humiliation the only two nations
sharing the island of hispaniola the dominican
republic and haiti have long defined themselves
in opposition to the other founded by a successful
slave rebellion haiti was defiantly black and
caribbean a nation where french creole was the
lingua franca trio side of the island by contrast
was spanish-speaking and firmly orientated towards
europe ever since a bitter two-decade occupation
by haitian forces ended in 1844 dominicans had
grown to see their neighbors not just as different
but as alien savages hence the lifelong horror
trio would feel at his own haitian roots hence
his desperate need as an adult to use makeup to
lighten his skin tone by the time he finally
reached power the goat would be so obsessed
with race that he'd dedicate himself to ridding
the dominican republic of its non-whites but all
of that was still way in the future for now young
raphael trio would lead the life of any other kid
from his area joining a local gang making a bit
of money through theft and forgery yet even as he
hung out at the bottom of the social chain forces
were at work that would soon conspire to take this
poor mix-raced boy to the very very top if haiti
was the dominican republic's hated sibling then
uncle sam was the playground bully who pantsed
them both and stole their lunch money as early as
1905 washington seized control of the dominican
customs agency to pay off debts effectively
holding its finances hostage but this was only
the beginning in 1915 woodrow wilson ordered
u.s marines to occupy haiti on the pretext of
maintaining order in the caribbean at the same
time washington started making noises about
also taking over the dominican republic if
it couldn't stabilize its politics predictably
the threat of u.s invasion did not stabilize
anything the dominican government collapsed
on the 7th of may 1916 u.s forces entered the
country it was the beginning of an eight-year
american occupation one that would completely
overturn the established order it was also the
beginning of raphael trio's rise to absolute power
the thing about embarking on an occupation
is that most people don't like their country
being occupied the entire time the americans
ran the dominican republic they had to deal
with a guerrilla movement one they simply didn't
have the manpower to overcome so they began to
recruit locals into a new national police force
the guardia nationale among its members would
be rafael trio in the years since we lost saw him
trio had gotten married ditched his life of crime
and gotten a legit job working security at a sugar
plantation but this was unglamorous underpaid work
unbecoming of a man as exceptional as trio thought
he was the new police force then was his ticket
out commissioned in january 1919 trio wasted no
time letting his true colors show you know how you
occasionally meet someone usually in an office who
has a tiny bit of power and just wields it like
that julius caesar well that was trio as a police
officer before it even been in the role seven
months he was reprimanded for extorting bribes and
sexually harassing teenage girls but rather than
being like maybe we shouldn't promote the creepy
sex pest the goat superiors allowed him to keep
rising up the ranks in the heat of noise of the
occupation the americans didn't care if they were
training nice people he just needed them to be
loyal and trio was a lap dog par excellence for
uncle sam in 1924 he'd be promoted to lieutenant
colonel by then though his benefactors had enough
by 1924 it was clear that the occupation was the
sort of hypocritical failure the u.s would soon
learn to excel at that july washington went screw
this then handed power to general horacio vasquez
as the last american troops ran for the exits
vasquez turned for support to the only power left
in the country the guardian nationale that was
the same guardian nacional raphael trujillo was
slowly taking over it took six years for the goat
to make his plans six years in which the guardian
astronaut was remade into the dominican army
and trio promoted to its chief finally in 1930
his moment came that february president vasquez
announced he would seek reelection something the
constitution was super clear that he wasn't
supposed to do in response the politician
raphael estrella urania whipped up a rebel force
which marched on the capital to chase him from
power before he marched though arena asked trio
to keep the army neutral in the upcoming fight
and trio agreed but not because he backed
urania no no no the goat had his own plan for
the upcoming transfer of power the moment vasquez
fled trio sprang into action with new elections
announced for may trio declared his candidacy
bullying irania into running as his vp that done
he unleashed what would soon become an all too
familiar wave of terror rather than fight fair
trio had his soldiers kidnap torture and kill
anyone against him journalists died in accidents
that certainly didn't look very accidental crowds
of opposition supporters had machine guns fired
into their midst as the tsunami of intimidation
threatened to drown their vote as the opposition
withdrew hoping to reveal to the world what a
sham the election was instead they handed trio
the keys to the kingdom on election day raphael
trillo pulled down 95 of the vote taking the
presidency in a landslide just four months later
a hurricane swept the republic devastating the
capital and killing some two thousand people
it was exactly the stroke of luck trio needed
under the guise of disaster relief trio imposed
martial law he confiscated opponents bank accounts
brought in press censorship and ended the right to
peaceful assembly just like that the era of chaos
and occupation in the dominican republic came
to an end in its place began an era of bloodshed
and unparalleled cruelty now we'll hear more
about that bloodshed in just a second but first
i've got a quick word from today's video sponsor
nordvpn now we've talked about vpns and their
benefits here before this isn't 1999 too many
people are looking for your internet history
bad actors trying to steal your data and your
personal information corporations tracking your
browser activity to bombard you with ads and no
one needs any of that that's why nordvpn is so
crucial it's based over in panama which makes it
a great option for both americans and europeans
and look a common misconception is that vpns are
just for people who are looking to play defense
but they're not just about protecting yourself
you'll be amazed at the different streaming
options you have when jumping on a server from
somewhere else in the world protect yourself or
just play around buy it for yourself or consider
it as a gift for another internet user in your
life with nordvpn you've got lots of options
plus a 30 day money back guarantee if it's not
for you there's never been a better time to
enhance your online experience with nordvpn
and that's because right now nordvpn is running
a great deal you guys can grab a two-year plan
at a hugely discounted cost plus an additional
four months for free so head to nordvpn.com
forward slash biographics and check it out that's
nordvpn forward slash biographics or just follow
the link in the description box
below and now back to the video
the speed with which the dominican republic
transformed into trio's personal fiefdom was
staggering to behold in the aftermath of
the hurricane political opponents began to
disappear or die in accidents and suicides before
long anyone who could possibly oppose the new
regime was dead in hiding or pretending to be a
loyalist his opposition neutralized al-jefe was
able to give his worst instincts free reign
today the dictatorship or the truiato as it's
locally known could be said to have three main
drivers centralization sycophancy and sadism
of these perhaps the key to its survival was
centralization all his professional life trio
had been an extreme micromanager a skill that he
soon brought to bear on the entire country almost
every pillar of dominican life was routed through
el jefe's office from education to religion to
entertainment to industry this allowed trio to
force through draconian reforms that whipped
the economy into shape saw the national debt
paid off and the country quickly modernized
roads unfurled across the landscape schools and
hospitals were built literacy levels leapt from an
abysmal 30 percent to a staggering 96 it was these
concrete achievements that dazzled his foreign
backers in the united states that led to moments
like democratic senator alan j ellender declaring
i wish there were a trio in every country of south
and central america but while centralization had
tangible ups it also had plenty of downs the
biggest being that trio kept all of the ups for
himself even as the economy modernized trio was
using state assets to forcibly buy out foreign
companies create monopolies and hand them over
to family members by his death it's estimated
that something like three-fifths of the nation's
workforce was under his control and up to 60
percent of its land was in his hands manufacturing
sugar plantations beer production airlines if it
could spin a profit it soon became part of the
goat's empire in fact it's this insatiable greed
that earned him their nickname in the first place
which brings us on to the regime's second trait
sycophancy the only people who called trio a goat
to his face were probably cerabides desperate
to experience a fun new kind of torture most
people used his official title benefactor of the
fatherland rebuilder of the financial independence
of the republic first journalist chief projector
of the dominican working class and genius of the
peace generalissimo dr trujillo it was an absurd
mouthful a word salad dressed with hypocrisy at
the same time though it revealed an essential
truth living under trio meant learning to massage
his gigantic ego that meant casting statues in
his likeness across the nation that meant the
government falling over itself to rename streets
parks mountains even the capital city after him
it meant neon signs blinking on roadsides flashing
the message trio and god into the humid night air
it meant every household being decorated with a
sign reading in this house trio as chief yet even
amid all this adulation that goat's vanity still
got the better of him as dictator trio took to
wearing elevator shoes to appear taller than his
natural five foot eight inches in later years he
added a corset to hold in his gut not that anyone
dared laugh as you recall the last pillar of the
triato was sadism and it was something el hefei
excelled at the tortures meted out by the secret
police were as inventive as they were painful
beatings electroshocks and mutilation awaited
anyone who stepped out of line there are even
long-standing rumors that several dissidents
were fed to sharks but even this had nothing on
what could happen if you were young and female
all his life rafael trio seems to have had an
unhealthy interest in young teenage girls as
an adult the goat would have girls kidnapped
and brought to one of his ranchers like casa
kayoba and once there well let's just say trio
may have had more in common with stalin's chief
sadist leventry barrier than we'd like to imagine
as bad as the horrors trio inflicted on his
people were it was the horrors visited upon
his neighbors that helped rankings
as one of history's great monsters
from a boy who despised his own mixed
background raphael trio had grown into a man
obsessed with racial purity in his mind the
dominican republic was forever in danger of
getting too dark of losing its european roots and
becoming like its hated neighbor haiti back then
the border between the two nations was relatively
porous haitians crossed for work or love and many
in the region had a mixed parentage then on
october the 2nd 1937 the soldiers came carrying
machetes they fanned out looking for haitians
or dominicans with haitian blood supposedly they
asked those with dark skin to pronounce the
spanish word for parsley per a yeel knowing
the haitians said it differently and so began the
parsley massacre one of the biggest acts of peace
type bloodletting the continent had ever seen over
a handful of days somewhere in the region of 17
000 haitians were hacked to death with machetes
their bodies burned fed to animals or just
thrown in the sea in the white heat of the
killing madness took hold one lieutenant
who heard of the massacre and wanted to impress
trio promptly marched home and shot his haitian
cook yet despite the genocidal nature of the
killings the goat suffered almost no consequences
sure he had to relinquish the presidency to a
puppet but he remained the one pulling the strings
sure the u.s forced him to pay conversation
to haiti but it amounted to a mere 525 000
pittance for every person killed nor did the
regime put a halt to its whitening policies
for observers at the time the flinging open of
the dominican republic's doors to refugees from
the spanish civil war and jews escaping nazi
persecution was puzzling especially as trio was
cozy with europe's fascists but it was simply the
soft flip side to the parsley massacre tree wanted
to drive black people out of his nation while
also inviting whites in the despot's hope was that
european refugees would intermarry with dominicans
thereby purifying his nation's race flagrantly
insane as all this is though you wouldn't know it
from looking at how the international community
reacted in the post-war era the u.s embraced
him fully trumpeting al-jefe's reforms and
anti-communism he met with president truman and
eisenhower then vice president richard nixon was
photographed clasping his hand and grinning
in europe catholic governments lined up to
celebrate his economic achievements the vatican
showered him with wards but even as he was playing
the golden boy on the world stage trio was still
up to his nasty old tricks out in the dominican
countryside peasants were being used as forced
labor on sugar plantations owned by the regime at
the same time the secret police was extending its
reach assassinating critics across the world most
famously this included phd student jesus galindez
who was writing a book on trio's dark side in
1956 he was kidnapped off the streets of new york
and flown to one of trio's private ranchers where
it's said that the goat forced him to eat his own
manuscript before in turn feeding his body to the
pigs eternal as al jeffy and his despotic regime
may have appeared though it would soon turn out
to be an illusion beneath the surface of dominican
society volcano was starting to rumble a volcano
of anger pent up from decades of living beneath
a capricious tyrant when it finally erupted there
would be nothing the benefactor of the fatherland
could do to stop his regime from going up with it
as the 1950s drew to a close trio was once again
reinventing his nation this time as a haven for
other despots colombian strongman gustavo arroyos
pania sought refuge there after being deposed
followed by venezuelan tyrant perez jimenez but it
was the dictator who arrived on january the 1 1959
who changed everything valencia batista had ruled
cuba with brutality easily equal to raphael tries
yet he'd been overthrown by a bunch of communist
rebels for everyone in the caribbean the cuban
revolution acted as a wake up call realizing
he might be vulnerable to a similar ousting
ajefe even signed a mutual assistance pact with
his great enemy haiti yet trio wasn't the only
one obsessed with castro's surprise victory within
a month of batista being overthrown the dominican
liberation movement had formed that june 1959
they sent an expeditionary force to overthrow the
goat although trio's forces crushed them it still
took a psychological toll in the wake of the coup
attempt el jefe began to get dangerously paranoid
it didn't help that the wider world was finally
waking up to his successes with his term almost
over president eisenhower was pressuring trio
to step down at the same time the organization
of american states oas was following the lead
of venezuela's president romulo bettencourt
in demanding the dominican republic return
to democracy shaken mistrustful trio responded
the only way he knew how on june the 24th 1960
the presidential car was driving bettencourt down
one of the main avenues in caracas when it was hit
by the mother of all explosions 65 kilos of tnt
detonators as it passed shattering the vehicle and
killing two people somehow president bettercourt
survived the next day he went on tv and told the
world who was behind the attack raphael trio it
was the beginning of the end of the dictatorship
although el jefe tried to claim the bombing was
carried out by rogue members of the security
forces no one bought it the dominican republic was
isolated internationally it couldn't have come at
a worse time just as the oas and trio's old u.s
back has cut ties the republic was lurching into
an economic crisis desperate for cash to prop up
his regime trio pivoted to moscow abandoning his
long-held anti-communist beliefs when that didn't
work he tried to find new scapegoats home accusing
roman catholic priests of a vast conspiracy
against him he even considered assassinating the
pope as he flailed on the world stage though el
jefe still had absolute power at home even in this
worsening economic crisis and climate paranoia no
one dared move against him by now trio's rule was
so absolute that he thought he was invincible that
his people were so cowed he got away with anything
he was about to find out just how wrong that
assumption was minerva mirabal was one of three
dominican sisters who acted as a professional
thorn in the dictator's side back in 1949 trio
had tried to coerce her into having sex with him
holding her father hostage and threatening her
family but mirabal had stared him down and in the
end the goat had blinked first ever since the two
had hated each other with a passion of hatred that
only grew as minerva and her two sisters began
plotting against the regime under the name
las mariposas or the butterflies in the late
1960s trio finally decided that it had enough that
november the 25th the butterflies were stopped in
the car by the regime's thugs abducted at gunpoint
they were savagely beaten their bodies then
loaded back into the car and rolled into the sea
it was a typical murder for trejo's goons the sort
of thing that happened on a near daily basis this
time though it didn't nerve the mirabal sisters
were young beautiful popular on the capital social
scene their horrific violent deaths touched people
in a way that the deaths of countless others
never had in the shattered broken bodies of
the butterflies it seems those who'd previously
been too scared or too loyal at last saw their
leaders through colours el jefe didn't know it
yet but from that moment on his days were numbered
on may the 30th 1961 a car full of men sat idling
by the road leading to san cristobal waiting for
their prey it was late evening a typical lush
dominican night further up the road three more
men lurked in the darkness guns loaded and ready
finally they saw it on route from the capital the
chauffeur driven chevrolet taking the old ghost
to one of his dalliances with a younger woman
as the car drew closer the men readied their guns
knowing this was their only chance the chevrolet
pulled level and the night exploded in gunfire
the shootout that ended the triato was the result
of a whole lot of people becoming a whole lot of
pissed off at their leaders increasing madness the
military was involved the opposition even the cia
helped supply weapons with that sort of backing
how could it possibly go wrong raphael trio's life
ended that night his bloodied form left sprawled
across the road age 69 he lost power as violently
as he gained it it was a triumphal moment one
still celebrated in the dominican republic today
it was also far from the end of the nightmare with
his father dead el jefe's son raf has returned to
the country and installed himself as the new boss
over the next few days nearly all the conspirators
and their extended families were murdered yet
ramfest just didn't have the goat's touch before
the year was out he and his entire trio family
would have fled into exile taking their plundered
loot with them in their place arose a reformist
government headed by juan bosch one that briefly
looked as if it might steer the country towards
democracy but then the military toppled him in a
coup and when his supporters took up arms uncle
sam stepped right back in with another occupation
under the americans new elections were held in
1966 returning old trio loyalist joachim bellagoo
as president a guy who'd clearly learned from his
old boss bellaguer would spend the next 12 years
rigging elections murdering opponents and having
over 10 000 people tortured voted out in 1978
he returned for an encore eight years later only
finally stepping down for good in 1996. trio may
have been long dead by then but his influence on
belgium was impossible to miss today the cost of
the triato remains unknown although it's likely
very high one estimate we saw put the number of
political murders from the period of 1916 to 1978
covering the first u.s occupation the trio years
and believers first hint as president at north of
50 000 that's a staggering figure in such a small
country one which at the moment of trio's death
at a population of just 3.5 million yet the true
toll of el jefe's reign might be even higher as
one of the first modern tyrants in the americas
rafael trio wrote the playbook that countless
others would follow monsters like augusto
pinochet jorge video and the generals in brazil
would all engage in trio-esque levels of depravity
while simultaneously casting themselves as
fervent anti-communists to play kate washington
after all they already knew such tactics worked
for all his over violence his sadism his sexual
perversions raphael trio managed to create a
world where presidents and politicians fell over
themselves to praise him at his height he'd been
a darling of washington a superstar in europe
a devil everyone was only too eager to pretend
was really a saint he may belong dead but the
life of el jefe is still capable of teaching
us a lesson of showing us what nightmares can be
born when our leaders willingly turn a blind eye
to the actions of a monster so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching